- [Narrator] When we
think about volcanoes,
we imagine these eruptive,
hot, violent gateways
to the center of the Earth.
And I spoke to a scientist
who spends the night in them.
- [Ken] My name is Ken
Sims, and I'm a professor
of isotope geology at the
University of Wyoming.
- [Narrator] Ken studies,
among other things, volcanoes.
And it's for a few reasons,
but one in particular.
- [Ken] You can start to forecast
the likelihood for another eruption.
- [Narrator] To get his research data,
he has to spend time in
them, sometimes, overnight.
So we're talking about what it feels like
to spend the night in an active volcano.
- [Ken] You're in a big crater.
It's spectacular; this is like
being in a steep, deep canyon
except for now it's circular
all the way around you.
There's a lava lake below you
and the summit is above you.
- [Narrator] Volcanoes
have a particular smell
because they're full of gas.
- [Ken] Those gasses are
very sulfurous, so they smell
strong and acrid, they
also have acids in 'em.
And so they're toxic.
- [Narrator] The air can
be dangerous to breathe in.
- [Ken] You know, you oftentimes
are wearing gas masks;
it's pretty hard to sleep with gas mask.
- [Narrator] And it's noisy.
- [Ken] It's echoey, typically,
you'll hear hissing.
- (metallic hissing)
- [Narrator] Instead of a campfire,
there's an active lava lake.
- [Ken] Looking at a lava lake is just
phenomenal that way, it's mesmerizing.
There's something about the
red warm glow, it's unworldly.
- [Narrator] There's a lot
to distract you from sleep.
But Sims says none of that matters.
(exploding)
- [Ken] You don't wanna go to bed.
This is how the Earth's surface formed
was from volcanoes, and
if you're in the moment,
it's amazing.
- [Narrator] That's so cool.